l'
effort d'entrée en arrivant
a eu la confirmation que l'équipage
est parti pour l'entrée
et vous pouvez voir qu'aki est le premier
à entrer dans la station spatiale internationale
et guinguin et suivi par demain
de l'agence spatiale européenne
beaucoup de câlins et de sourires en ce moment
pilote euh megan macarthur  de l'équipage 2 est
ensuite accueilli par les membres de l'équipage de l'expédition 65
et shane kimbrough fermant la marche l'
équipage de 11 personnes de l'expédition 65 maintenant
ensemble à l'
intérieur de deux de la station spatiale internationale
bien que nous ne puissions même pas entendre l'audio là-dedans,
vous pourriez
ressentez vraiment l'excitation juste par les regards sur
leurs visages
les câlins qu'ils donnent
maintenant qu'ils se préparent pour cette
cérémonie d'accueil officielle,
vous pouvez les voir se mettre en position
avec le jeu tetris consistant à intégrer 11
membres d'équipage dans un seul cadre commencer
bon
douze quenguin oh c'est vrai
station mme houston êtes-vous prêt pour
l'événement
hé merci joseph c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment incroyable d'être ici sur sp  ace
station la station spatiale a pas mal
changé depuis la dernière fois que j'étais ici je n'ai
jamais vu autant d'astronautes à bord
je n'ai jamais vu autant de
vaisseaux spatiaux différents à bord et je pense que c'est un
hommage à la force du
programme je  Je veux faire écho à ce que
Megan a, euh,
dit qu'il a demandé beaucoup d'efforts de toutes
sortes de personnes que vous connaissez, du
plus haut responsable à euh toutes sortes de
personnes de soutien pour nous amener ici, donc nous
voulons
tous les remercier euh et je veux  dis quelques
mots sur la
coopération internationale tu as beaucoup parlé mais
euh ça fait 20 ans que euh
ça fait 20 ans en fait ça a changé je l'ai
appris de shane 20 ans depuis que
jackson et isa et la nasa et l'
astronaute russe sont ensemble dans l'espace donc
c'est en fait  assez historique ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
euh nous avons hâte de commencer notre travail sur
la station spatiale nous avons hâte de voir
ce qui nous attend dans l'aventure euh
pendant ces cinq mois nous sommes si heureux de
voir nos amis nous sommes  va devoir
dire g  au revoir bientôt on aimerait pouvoir les
garder un peu plus longtemps mais
pas trop longtemps aussi parce que 11 personnes
c'est beaucoup sur la station spatiale euh mais ouais
c'est bien d'être là vraiment on est
impatient
et euh et ça va être incroyable
je veux voir
est
étranger